Hello.
Good.
Good afternoon, everyone. Welcome to our mini symposium on
genomic approaches to understanding tumor evolution. I'm Hui Shen.
I'm from the Van Andel Institute in Grand Rapids, Michigan, and I'm co-chairing
this session with Dr. Arnav Mehta, oncologist
from Stanford and venture partner from the Column Group.
Let me set the stage briefly. So the central
problem for cancer evolution can be put quite simply,
tumors change. So they change as they develop, as they spread,
as we treat them. And these changes can be genetic
or non-genetic, and interact with the selective
microenvironment, and at any point can consist of functional or
driver or non-functional or passenger events.
So genomic profiling is a very powerful tool in
profiling and cataloging these events, and
increasingly,
to decode the logic behind them. So we're at a
moment where cataloging is turning into interpretations, and
we try to understand
which of these
changes matter, when they occur, and why they occur, where
they do.
So we have seven great talks today that
showcase the power of genomic
methods in tracking and understanding these changes
in tumor evolution. And these talks
covers cancers that arise from different organ sites, and they
methodologically
span the full modern toolkit of whole genome
functional screens, population scale whole genome sequencing, whole exome
sequencing, single cell multi-omics, spatial transcriptomics,
and so will be truly
intellectually stimulating today.
Each talk will be 10 minutes, followed by a five-minute Q&A session.
For the audience with questions, please come to these mics so everybody can hear
you. And then Dr. Mehta will deliver the
closing remarks. Without much ado, let's get
started. Please welcome our first speaker, Dr.
Charlotte Grieco from CRUK.
Good afternoon. My name is Charlotte Grieco.
I am a medical oncology resident in London, and a clinical PhD
student with Charlie Swanton at the Francis Crick Institute.
I'm very pleased today to present our work on multiple primary lung cancers within
TRACERx.
And I have no financial relationships.
So multiple primary lung cancers represent a growing clinical challenge.
Improved lung cancer survival over the last 50 years
has increased the window of opportunity for second primaries occurring.
Lung cancer survivors also have a five times greater risk of a second
primary tumor relative to the general
population. But distinguishing second primaries
from relapses or metastases represents a major unmet need.
Limited clinical criteria exist.
We use the timing of events, clinical reports, and
pathological interpretation to try and disentangle this, but there's no
definitive gold standard.
Despite recommendations for the use of sequencing in this
context, this is heavily underutilized,
and understanding the genomic and molecular determinations
of these tumors remains unclear. Prior studies
include pre-invasive lesions,
cohorts are skewed towards East Asian predominant genetic
ancestry, and many of the studies use panel
sequencing to do this.
TRACERx was designed to study the evolution of non-small cell lung
cancer from early stage through complete surgical resection,
through recurrence or cure.
Patients were permitted to have more than one primary tumor, as long as both
primary tumors at the time of registration were treated with curative
intent.
These patients were then followed up over time, undergoing sampling of
metastatic disease, but also sampling of new primary tumors should they
occur during follow-up.
All samples were subject to high-depth whole exome sequencing, as well
as other molecular characterizations.
We can use all of this data, plus detailed clinical data, to
understand the evolution of these tumors within the patient host,
either single tumors or multiple tumors.
So the overarching aim of our project is to characterize multiple lung
primaries through integrated genomic, microenvironmental,
and clinical data to try to improve diagnosis and to
inform treatment strategies.
Today, I'll address three main questions.
Firstly, how confidently can we distinguish these multiple
primaries from metastases?
Secondly, what's driving multiple primary tumors within patients?
Is it germline risk, or are there features of environmental exposure
affecting the host?
And finally, how molecularly similar are these tumors within patients?
We define multiple primary tumors in TRACERx in several ways.
Firstly, a patient may have had
a prior cancer before study recruitment, but this must have
occurred more than three years prior to registration.
Secondly, a patient may have had synchronous primary tumors, both
present on the baseline imaging.
Often, these tumors are resected at separate time points.
Finally, a patient may develop a metachronous
tumor occurring during the follow-up time period, either within
the lung or within another organ
site.Using the whole exome
sequencing data available for these patients, we were able to compare the
genomic relatedness versus clinical determinations of
these multiple primary tumors.
So in the clinic, relatedness is determined through pathology review,
review of imaging, and also assessing the timing of these events.
We define genomic relatedness of tumors as the sharing of 10 or
more mutations through whole exome sequencing.
And across the cohort, we see that there is a 10% discordance
in clinical and genomic relatedness.
This occurs in several ways.
Firstly, at baseline, we saw that 3 out of 30
genomically unrelated pairs were clinically treated as metastases.
Now, this has significant implications for treatment.
This may have upstaged patients, and they may have therefore had adjuvant
therapy that was perhaps not required.
Secondly, during follow-up, this occurs in
two directions.
Firstly, we observed that five genomically unrelated pairs were
actually diagnosed as metastases.
More commonly, however, we saw that 11 genomically related
tumors were diagnosed as new primaries.
And this, again, has significant implications.
These patients potentially had stage four disease and then didn't actually get the
systemic therapy that they may have needed.
So 1 in 10 patients were perhaps not accurately diagnosed and treated
as a result of not using sequencing of their relapse or
new primary lesions.
So how does our cohort look?
Across all patients in TRACERx, we see 25% have more than
one primary tumor. The range is from one to four
additional primary tumors.
Looking across tumor subtypes, you can see that the vast majority of these tumors
are occurring within the lung,
with approximately half of these occurring at baseline and half during
follow-up.
Interestingly, those with a prior cancer, representing about
10% of the cohort, span multiple organ
sites. However, when we look at tumors occurring during follow-up,
they're more likely to occur in smoking-related tumors, such as upper
GI or bladder.
For the rest of the talk, I'll focus on the lung multiple primary cohort.
12% of patients in TRACERx had more than one lung multiple primary.
The majority had just one additional tumor, either occurring at baseline
or during follow-up.
However, a small proportion of patients had more than one additional lung cancer,
and these represent our greatest clinical unmet need.
The shaded bars demonstrate those for which we have sequencing data for.
This cohort is 114 tumors across 58
patients.
So now looking at the histological
landscape of our cohort, which you can see here.
Each column represents a patient and each row a tumor.
Adenocarcinomas are seen in the dark red, squamous carcinomas
in dark blue, and other non-small cell lung cancers are seen
in gray.
Clearly, adenocarcinomas dominate this landscape.
Of note, if you look at the lower bar here of smoking status, you can see that
most patients have some sort of smoking exposure, with only three patients
being never smokers.
This is a
much lower proportion than you might expect to see in a UK lung cancer cohort.
We look to explore the pairwise differences in histology across the cohort
by comparing the baseline tumor histology to the additional tumors.
And here you can see that there is a patient-specific tendency towards
histology, particularly seen within the LUAD subtype.
Now, this may be due to host factors or environmental
exposures.
We started to then look at what might be driving these multiple lung primary
tumors.
Firstly, we looked at germline pathogenic variants in cancer predisposition
genes, and we didn't see an enrichment in the cohort with multiple lung
primary tumors.
However, when we reviewed cumulative tobacco exposure measured
through pack-year history, we saw a significantly higher
median pack-year history in the
lung multiple primary cohort.
This
suggests that perhaps germline predisposition is not as important as
environmental exposures in developing more than one lung cancer.
We then sought to explore the genomic characteristics of tumors from patients with
multiple primaries versus those with only one lung cancer.
We explored three genomic metrics:
chromosomal instability measured through the weighted genome instability
index, mutations per tumor, and also the rate of driver
mutations. As you can see, there is no significant
difference between tumors from patients with a single primary versus
those with multiple primary tumors.
So multiple primary tumors do not seem to have distinct genomic
features.
Finally, we sought to understand whether tumors within a
patient shared common driver pathways.
We looked at the proportion of
mutations in shared driver genes within patients,
seen here at 12% in the red dashed line.
We performed permutation testing where we took random pairs of
tumors from the cohort matched by histology and smoking
status to see whether there was any specific enrichment in
mutations in shared genes within patients.
And as you can see here, there's no specific enrichment within
patients.So we can
conclude that multiple primary tumors seem to be as genomically divergent
as those from different patients altogether.
This supports the hypothesis that independent tumor initiation events are
likely driven in this cohort by stochastic
exposure-related mutagenesis rather than a
patient-specific pathway.
I think this is particularly interesting because these tumors look
as different as any tumors from
any patient, but they've developed within the same host with the
same environmental exposures.
So to conclude, multiple primary tumors are common.
25% of TRACERx patients have more than one primary cancer,
and 12% more than one lung primary.
One in 10 cases were clinically misclassified without using
whole-exome sequencing data, risking inappropriate treatment for those
cases.
Tumors within a patient are likely to share histology, but genomically
they seem as divergent as tumors between patients.
Our future work will combine these genomic insights with host
immune factors and also therapy data to try and
understand why these tumors are evolving independently within
patients and how that might be occurring.
I'd like to extend a special thanks to the team, particularly Lydia,
Adriana, and Christina, who've put a lot of time and effort into this project, as
well as the other clinicians, pathologists, and bioinformaticians you can see here.
I'd also like to acknowledge the wider lab team, all our funders,
including Cancer Research UK, and of course, the patients and their families
involved in TRACERx.
Thank you very much, Charlotte. Do we have questions from the audience?
Please come to the mic, please. Thank you.
Thank you very much for the nice presentation. I have a question.
Why do you define relatedness based only on SNVs,
and why not copy number alterations?
In other words, I think it's really unlikely for two unrelated
tumors to share a common breakpoint.
It's a very good question. Today, in 10 minutes, I'm only able to show a small
amount of data, but this is something we are also looking at.
That was actually my question, but now I have another one.
When you said you define clonal relatedness greater than 10 mutations-
Yes
... is that correct? And these are any, not drivers.
Yes.
So I can explain the process. So we basically generate these
sequencing heat maps, and we compare
within patients the tumors, but we look at the distribution of the
mutations across the variants called.
So we can see very clear, separate clonal populations in making those
definitions.
I might have missed this, but did you show that in the multiple lung primaries,
what was the shared drivers?
As in specific genes?
Specific lung, like EGFR mutations,
ROS1, ALK fusions.
We don't see much evidence of shared drivers actually at all.
And within this cohort, there's only one patient with an EGFR mutation that's a
driver mutation.
Wow.
So it's not
obvious clinical drivers that we might target in the clinic that we see in this
population generally.
There are some drivers shared, often TP53,
but they don't seem to be enriched really.
Okay, thank you.
Are there any more questions from the audience?
If not, I have one that's related to both the two questions
asked. So you used 10 as the cutoff for the mutation-
Mm-hmm
... to call whether it's genomically related or not.
Mm-hmm.
So what is the overall distribution of the shared number of
mutation look like? So why specifically 10?
And
are there any mutation-sparse tumors
that this absolute number would be
difficult to use? Yeah.
So the cutoff of 10 was established a long time before I joined the lab.
Uh-huh.
And actually, I think from the evidence we've shown, the fact that it's very
unlikely even to share any driver mutations, I think 10 is actually quite a
rigorous cutoff.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah.
Thank you.
I have one other question.
Do you see any survival differences for patients that have
multiple primaries? Do you think of them as sort of independent events that
kind of influence survival, or is there some-
Mm-hmm
... relationship?
So I haven't shown this data today, but we do see some survival differences
within the cohort. We have to kind of split this up based on the type of
multiple primary that the patient had because, of course, the treatment differs in
each group.
For those with synchronous primaries, we do see that their survival is
poorer, but I think it's quite hard to disentangle whether this is due to the
cancer progression or whether it's a factor of treatment-related
toxicity or
treatment-related side effects.
Interestingly, in those that develop a metachronous lung cancer,
the survival differences aren't as marked, and I wonder whether this is because
those are patients who are already under a lung cancer pathway, they have
close follow-up, and we're picking them up quite early.
Fantastic. Thank you, Charlotte.
Okay.
Thank you.
Great. Next, we have Sebastian Mueller from the Technical University of
Munich, who's going to tell us about the Mouse Cancer Cell Line Atlas.
Thank you very much.
So yeah, thank you very much for giving me the opportunity to speak here
today and to present our work.
I have nothing to disclose.
To start with, the Human Cancer Cell Line Encyclopedia has become an
indispensable resource in cancer research, not only because of
the systematic characterization of these cell lines at different
levels, but also through the chance of functional perturbating
those cell lines.
However, no such resource exists for the mouse, despite
the fact that the mouse is the most important mammalian model
organism in cancer research.
So because of that, we initiated the Mouse Cancer Cell Line Atlas,
which so far comprises 590 different cell
lines from 22 different lineages, as you can see here.
And we systematically characterize these cell lines at multiple levels, so
genomics, transcriptomics, cell morphology, histopathology,
clinical metadata, and we also annotated
immunophenotypes.
So what are these immunophenotypes or what is the
immunophenotype of a mouse cell line?
We define it from three factors: genetic background, MHC
haplotype, and gender.
And why is that important? Because in contrast to human cell
lines, we can transplant mouse cell lines into immunocompetent mice.
But the only problem here is that
typically, the immunophenotype of a mouse line is not well known.
So because of that problem, we developed a computational
tool, StrainMapper, which allows us to
identify genetic background, MHC haplotype, and gender
from genomic sequencing data of a mouse
line. Once we know that,
so we did that for all 590
MCCA lines, and once we have this immunophenotype
information, we can precisely match the mouse line to an
immunocompetent recipient mouse, which then allows us to use these
lines for immunocompetent transplantations.
So all the data that we generated in the Mouse Cancer Cell Line
Atlas is available through this website, and it allows
also to explore this data through cBioPortal Web
Interface.
So
what we wanted to do with the Mouse Cancer Cell Line Atlas is to better understand
tissue-specific cancer evolution, and this builds
on previous work that we have done in the pancreas. So a little detour here.
At that time, we studied KRAS driven oncogenesis in mice,
where pancreatic cancers are induced by one copy of mutant KRAS.
We found that two-thirds of these cancers actually
acquired during their evolution, a second copy
of the mutant KRAS. So this is not a high-level amplification.
This is just one copy of mutant KRAS that is more.
And we found that this dosage increase of the mutant allele is
acquired relatively early during cancer evolution in the precursor
stage, and this is also linked to metastasis.
When the cancers do not amplify KRAS or gain a second
copy of KRAS, they amplify alternative oncogenes.
So to keep it short, we simplified this in a model where
pancreatic cancer evolution starts with one copy of mutant KRAS, and
depending on whether you gain a second copy of mutant KRAS or amplify
alternative oncogenes, this then has important implications
for the cancer phenotype. So metastasis,
cell morphology, histopathology, and growth
aggressiveness. Which way you go depends
on the type of tumor suppressor gene loss, and this is what we found through
phylogenetic analysis. So homozygous loss of CDKN2A
is required to allow for this dosage gain of mutant KRAS.
The same can be achieved through loss of p53.
But when we knocked out TGF-beta
pathway,
we found that this leads only to a heterozygous loss of CDKN2A, which
is compatible with amplification of these alternative
oncogenes.
So conceptually, at the time,
we concluded that when we want to understand cancer phenotypes, in
this case in the pancreas,
we should not only have a look at mutations, but we need to include two additional
dimensions, the dosage of a mutation and its evolution.
So now we wanted to investigate if these
insights also apply to other cancer types which have frequent KRAS mutations,
and this is where we used the Mouse Cancer Cell Line Atlas.
So we included now lung and intestinal cancers, which are
all induced by oncogenic KRAS in the mice.
And we found that
all of them frequently gain a second copy of the mutant KRAS.
So please ignore the details here. So they frequently amplify KRAS.
The same can be seen in human cancer cell lines and human cancer tissues.
And we also found that this dosage increase of the mutant allele has
prognostic relevance.
The question was then, when during cancer evolution
dosage of KRAS is increased? And what I have just shown you before is in
the pancreas, this is an early event.
So when we looked at cancer evolution in
the intestine-- So in the lung here, sorry, and in the intestine, we
found that their dosage increase of KRAS
typically occurs in the carcinoma state.
So in the lung and in the intestine, KRAS
dosage increase occurs late during cancer evolution.
But in the pancreas, it's an early event.
And then we, of course, wanted to know how does it come, the difference in the
timing, and
we performed many different experiments, and this is the one
that was most informative for us. So here we overexpressed different
levels of oncogenic KRAS in non-transformed
human pancreatic and intestinal cells.
What we found is that in both models, KRAS induces more oncogenic signaling.
That's to be expected. But specifically in the pancreas, we found
dedifferentiation signatures.
We further validated this in a second model of pancreatic
acinar cells. So here we performed a similar experiment,
and we found that the KRAS induces dedifferentiation of acinar
cells into ductal-like progenitor cells.
And the interesting observation was here
thatHigh levels of oncogenic K-RAS
were required to induce this dedifferentiation process.
And this case gave us the idea that
because dedifferentiation is the very first step of oncogenesis in the pancreas,
which requires high levels of RAS, that this is the reason why RAS is amplified so
early during cancer evolution, specifically in the pancreas.
In the intestine, the situation is very different.
So
K-RAS induced proliferation in this context, and
this is however, not of selective advantage in the intestine
because the intestine is anyway highly proliferative.
So what you need to achieve is to escape this rapid epithelial
turnover in the intestine. And this is mediated through block of
differentiation, which is typically acquired through Wnt pathway activation.
So if our idea is right that RAS is not
contributing to this block of differentiation, we would expect to see Wnt pathway
alterations in the intestine. And this is exactly what we can find here.
So,
in the adenomas,
they typically acquire somatic mutations in APC and
beta-catenin to activate the Wnt pathway.
So remember, this is the RAS-induced, serrated
pathway of intestinal cancer evolution.
So which starts with
activation of RAS, which induced proliferation,
then we have adenoma formation, which is independent of RAS.
Here we have the Wnt pathway activation to block differentiation, and only
after this step is acquired, RAS can be amplified to
drive further progression to the carcinoma state.
So,
what about
K-RAS tumor suppressing interactions?
We previously also found that CDKN2A loss is almost
universal event in the pancreas. This is also what we see here in MCCA, but
interestingly, this was not the case in intestinal and lung
cancers.
And this was a bit surprising to us, to be honest, because all these cancers are
induced by the same oncogene.
We found that this pattern is also conserved in human cancers.
And then again, the question was: How does that come?
What's the reason for that? And the explanation is relatively
simple,
because what we found is that the chromatin state of CDKN2A, so
CDKN2A activity differs between healthy tissues.
So in the pancreas, CDKN2A locus has an active
chromatin state, so active
histone marks, but in the intestine it's polycomb
repressed. So the idea here is that specifically in the pancreas,
RAS can
activate CDKN2A mediated tumor suppression. This is why it needs to be deleted.
And to test this, we looked at CDKN2A,
mediated or induced senescence,
and we found that senescence is only robustly induced by K-RAS
in the pancreas, but not in the other tissues, explaining why it's just
lost in the pancreas.
Okay, so to sum that up,
another simplified model. Here,
cancer evolution is initiated by the same oncogene,
and
in all cancer types, dosage increase is a common phenomenon.
But the timing of this dosage increase differs between the tissues.
So in the pancreas, it's an early event because RAS
dosage increase is required for this early dedifferentiation.
In the intestine, it's a relatively late event because here RAS
induces proliferation, but we need to activate Wnt pathway
to escape this rapid epithelial turnover.
And after block of differentiation is acquired, RAS dosage increase can
drive progression to
the carcinoma.
What's also interesting about this
model is it can explain an old observation in
mice where K-RAS is induced in all cells of the body.
These mice typically develop lung cancer, but not intestinal or
pancreatic cancers. And the answer to that is,
because in the pancreas, tumorigenesis is restrained by
CDKN2A. In the intestine, it requires Wnt pathway
activation. But in the lung, no such barrier exists.
And because of that, RAS can drive
multifocal lung carcinogenesis in this
tissue. Okay.
With that, I would like to finish and thank all our collaborators for their
generous support.
Big thanks also to Roland and Dieter supporting all of this, and
Niklas and Marcus, who did a great job on this
project and was happy to work with them together.
So yeah, thanks for your attention.
We welcome any questions at the microphone.
So maybe Sebastian, just one question on my end.
I think as a field, we are often challenged in comparative analysis
with some of the mouse tumor lines and human tumor lines.
Be interested in your thoughts on
the conservations of the copy number events across the
atlases, and perhaps what that means also for the adaptive
transcriptional programs, which is often the harder thing to interpret across
species.
Yeah. So,
for sure there's a difference between mice and humans.
So mouse tumors have less mutations, less copy number
alterations. And
we are working on this for a while already, and so what our
idea is basically that the mouse has less,
but this gives you a cleaner view on what are the dependencies,
and this helps you to better understand what happens in the human
tumors. Because sometimes
in the humans it looks different, but once you understand how it works in the
mouse, then you say, like, "Okay, in the humans, I forgot to
consider this and that," and then suddenly it makes sense.
For example-We find this dependency
of RAS on CDKN2A loss, and if you do the
same kind of analysis in humans, you don't see that pattern.
But once we understood that P53 loss does the same,
we then
removed all the P53 inactivated tumors in the humans, and
suddenly we saw the same pattern as in the mouse.
So I think we can learn a lot from the mice, and
yeah. But there's some difference for sure, but
it's helping us a lot. Yeah.
I have another question. So you kind of got to that a little bit in the end of
your answer to Anna's question. So you showed really
nice vignettes of KRAS and CDKN2A, and I
wanted to ask, are they in the whole atlas
analysis, are they more the exceptions or are they more like the rules, the tissue
specificity that you discussed and all these features?
Yeah. So, we really focused on
these three tissues.
Yeah.
But I think,
yeah, this is what we are going to expand in the next
years,
that we include more genotypes, for example.
But we see really differences like how
tumors, how they evolve in
different genetic contexts, if they are metastasizing or
not, and
yeah. And we can all modulate this in the mouse. That's the cool thing.
Yeah. Very cool.
Yeah.
It's an incredible resource.
And yeah, especially with the humans, with the TCGA data, which is available,
we can really look at patterns and then modulate this in the mouse and see
how this influence survival, metastasis, and progression and all
these things that are not possible to do in the humans.
That's great.
Thank you.
Well, we're perfectly on time. Thank you.
So our next speaker is Dr. Colin Lindsay from University of
Manchester, and he's going to talk about allele-specific KRAS mutation
signatures. So a little bit more on KRAS.
Okay. Thank you very much.
So yeah, I'm a lung cancer medical oncologist with a
specific interest in KRAS precision medicine.
What I'm going to present to you today is the work of an outstanding
PhD student, Laura Woodhouse, who's just defended her PhD.
The reason she's not here today is she's imminently expecting her first
baby, so I'm going to try and do this on her behalf.
And she was co-supervised between myself and David Wedge, who
some of you may know was involved with the description of cosmic mutational
signatures from his days at the Sanger over 10 years ago now.
So lung cancer has immense global impact in terms of cancer
cell mortality still in particular.
There's
about twice as many cancer cell deaths still in the Western world from lung cancer
compared to any other cancer. This is mainly due to
most cases being diagnosed at the incurable
stage four setting.
When we talk about the genomic revolution for lung cancer, we
principally describe the adenocarcinoma subset, which is the
largest subset of non-small cell lung cancer.
You can see here, for instance, with KRAS mutation in
adenocarcinoma, and there's 25% of cases affected in
this pie chart. But depending on which analysis you look at, it could extend
up to 40% of cases.
And then in parallel to cosmic signatures being described, actually in
2013, we had the first putative inhibitor of
KRAS G12C first
described in the Showcat lab at UCSF, and we're at a
point now where we have an explosion of KRAS precision medicine.
You may know that deraxone RAS of the pan RAS inhibitor, for instance, is changing
survival now in pre-treated pancreatic cancer.
For those of you who've just seen this, but for those of you not so familiar with
KRAS point mutations, gastrointestinal tumors
tend to dominate with the most common mutations across cancer, which
are G12D and G12V, and that's pancreatic as
well. In lung cancer, we have G12C as the most common
subgroup in about 40% of cases, so a glycine to
cysteine point mutation.
For understandable reasons, G12C in particular is
considered to be the smoking related mutation.
But I think some of the point of this study is really to challenge the view that
KRAS mutation overall was related to smoking, and you'll see that
in the rest of our data.
Building on what I've just said, smoking tends to cause transversion
changes, and so most of the point mutations are
transversions with KRAS, but there are two or three transition
mutations that occur regularly with KRAS as well in lung
cancer.
So we wanted to challenge, maybe not a dogma, but certainly a
conception whereby KRAS mutant lung cancer is generally
ascribed to smoking.
And it was obvious to ask how cosmic signatures align with KRAS
mutation, its subtypes, and also at the end of our
study, we wanted to be able to move towards some sort of causality as well.
Can we use the signatures to really see if they are
directly causing individual KRAS
variants? And before I move on to our methods
and results, I'd just highlight that we see patients twice weekly in
the clinic, and the stigma of smoking is pervasive and very,
very real on both sides. So we have patients who have smoking related
cancers, and they feel incredibly guilty when you question them
about it. They feel almost as if they deserve their cancer, and they ask
you for very little and tend to thank you for everything.
But equally, we have the bereft feelings of patients who have a KRAS mutant lung
cancer and who have never smoked in their life, and people tend to assume that
they have smoked.So cosmic mutational
signatures are a taxonomy
of the smoking imprint in terms of mutations occurred from
any given sample from fertilization all the way through to the point of
biopsy or resection. There are now about
170 cosmic mutational signatures
described. These can be started off as
single-base substitution signatures.
There are also double base signatures, indel signatures, and
larger structural variant signatures as well.
But for the purposes of the talk, we'll probably focus on the smoking signatures,
SBS4, EBS2, and ID3 to a lesser extent
characterized by C to A change and environmental
influences obviously. UV light causes C to T
change in melanoma. We're also going to refer to aging and
clock-like changes with characteristic C to T change, in
particular in SBS1, also for SBS5 and
40. And of course, we have the things like defective DNA
damage repair and APOBEC changes that have been described in lung cancer
too. Our cohort for looking at this question
was a Genomics England 100,000 Genome Project.
And so this, to our knowledge, is the largest
cohort of whole genomes for smoking-related lung
cancer, at least in the Western world.
And it's all been done through a single program in the UK.
People who know about signatures will be aware that it offers you
incredible resolution to look at cosmic mutational signatures using the
genome as opposed to the exome. It's something like a 30 to
100 times fold improvement in your resolution by looking at the
genome. And you can see how big our cohort is here with
298 KRAS mutant adenocarcinomas, and we're
comparing with 379 KRAS wild types.
There's good representation of the common subtypes we expect to see.
But with such a large cohort, we also had good
representation of mutations in hotspots at 13 and
61.
So what Laura first did was she performed an
unsupervised analysis, extracting signatures from
our adenocarcinoma cohort, and 64 signatures, you can see along
the bottom here, were extracted.
We have KRAS mutant information in the first column here, and each
row represents a different patient tumor.
Our clustering analysis, unsurprisingly, revealed a
smoking cluster, cluster two, this sort of
nasty purple color in 75% of cases, and you can
see smoking signatures here. Following that, we have an APOBEC cluster
three, and you can see the APOBEC signatures here.
And then down at the bottom, we have the cluster one, another
biologically separate process, seemingly that's non-APOBEC, that's
non-smoking related and is characterized more in the way of
deployed genomes and chromosomal
stability. Laura overlaid these clusters
onto our KRAS variants, and what you can see is there are one
or two variants, such as 12S and 13C and 13D,
where smoking cluster two completely dominates.
But most other variants actually have some representation from
beyond cluster two, the smoking cluster.
Laura then went on to
look at the supervised information, the knowledge that we have
compared KRAS mutation versus wild type in
this cohort. And across the whole KRAS mutant cohort,
unquestionably, we see heavy representation from all three
smoking signatures here. Also, positivity
for copy number one, one of the deployed signatures.
In general, there are many more signatures represented in the KRAS wild type
side.
And loosely, they represented things like APOBEC, HRD, and
chromosomal instability.
Things became, I think, at least more interesting when we started to
overlay the mutant-specific information, and again,
look at the clusters that we drew out.
So for instance, we have a transversion, a transition here that are
still represented by smoking with codon
13. 12D and wild type, I can tell you when we switched them on in
the wet lab in isogenic models, they behave absolutely,
completely differently. But at this point, they only have clock-like representation
as their dominant signature. G12A is more
related to the deployed signature, and G12C and V, some of you may
have been at the session on Saturday, and the
biochemistry and the downstream signaling between these two are quite
fundamentally different, but ultimately, the smoking input
leads to similarities at this stage.
So moving on to the final part of what we wanted to achieve.
I mentioned at the beginning that we were trying to implicate direct
causality. Do these signatures look like they're directly
causing KRAS mutations in some or all cases?
And I'll remind you about the transversions and transitions.
And what we used
is the SigProfiler assignment algorithm.
And the basis behind this is that 98% of
KRAS mutations are single-base substitutions, and
this algorithm lends itself in particular to the SBS
classification. And what Laura did, in particular, I
think, is you take trinucleotide plots from each
individual tumor. You can see this is a tumor with G12C,
and then you map that back onto the reference cosmic genomes to estimate a
probability that
whether any given signature has caused the KRAS
mutation in any given tumor.
And our results, I think, were really quite interesting because
it was onlyG12C, G12V,
G13C, and perhaps Q61L
that seem to be directly caused by smoking,
SBS4 in particular. And each dot in this
plot here represents a different tumor.
We also found the next most significant signatures that we
extracted for this analysis were the aging and clock-like signatures 5 and
40. And so those signatures were far more likely to
be directly causative for G12A, a transversion,
G12D,
G13D, and perhaps Q61H as
well. But I'd probably just draw your attention to G13D and
G12V as well. I showed you earlier that at least indirectly,
they were very heavily associated with smoking in their genomes.
But despite that,
the smoking signature doesn't seem to be directly
implicated in causing these mutations.
And just one final slide where you can see each individual tumor
with each subtype in the column. It can sometimes be daunting to look at
smoking signatures in lung cancer.
I think people presume that your
lung cancer genome
almost won't be worth assessing. So it was really nice to see that we start
to see some order when we look through the lens of KRAS mutant
subtypes in terms of smoking contributions.
And for instance, it does seem like smoking may select for
variants like 13D and 12A, but it doesn't have a dominant
contribution, but it's always present.
With 12D, perhaps not. There's tumors that don't
have any smoking contribution, and it's light when
it's present. And 12V is interesting because there's
dominant smoking contribution, but some tumors in there that don't
have any smoking contribution at all.
I think it's reasonable that we can now say that 12C and 13C are
smoking related based on this analysis.
And I'll finish off by just reminding you this is as robust
an analysis that we could think of for this question.
We used a very large whole genome sequencing cohort, and we could look at
rare variants as well. We've done an unsupervised and supervised
analysis. I haven't been able to show you, we've been
able to do some co-mutational profiling and also some
epidemiological overlay with smoking information as well to validate
this. The take homes are indirectly, without doubt,
KRAS mutant lung cancer associates with smoking, and to a lesser
extent, chromosomal stability. But the direct
impact of smoking seems to be there only for
12C, 13C, and 12V.
And lastly, I've mentioned the potential impact this could
have in the clinic in the day-to-day in terms of smoking stigma.
But reasonably, I think this work could be extended and
used to inform public health messaging and personalized prevention in the
future. So I'll thank David Wedge and his
lab, who really had the intellectual input here.
Laura's been an outstanding medical oncology fellow now
going back to the clinic. We couldn't do anything without
pathology and biobank services. Thanks to our funders and the
patients and the relatives that we'll continue to advocate on their behalf.
Fantastic talk, Colin. So maybe one question on my end is,
we know all the RAS mutations have different hydrolysis rates and effects on MAP
kinase signaling. And so one explanation might suggest, is there
any reason to believe that the G12D mutations have a higher rate of
penetrance? So even though they might be less frequent in
pre-neoplastic lesions, that they would actually
manifest in mature tumors. Do you have any data sets
to compare pre-neoplastic
distributions of RAS?
Yeah. Great question. And I have actually heard G12D
almost referred to as the default KRAS mutation.
Clearly, it's the most common KRAS mutant variant as well.
We've seen with pancreas, for instance, the variant prevalence
seems to be matching what you see in cancer in
the pre-neoplastic setting or the pan-in setting.
My understanding, although TRACERx has unquestionably begun to interrogate this and
report this, is that we don't necessarily have that level of
information to know how much the pre-malignant tissue
matches the cancer.
Great.
Any other? Great. Thank you, Colin.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Right. Next we have Dr. Elizabeth Brunk from UNC Chapel Hill,
who's going to talk to us about gene amplification, architecture, and expression.
Okay. Hi, everyone. Thank you for being here.
I want to say I have nothing to disclose.
And I want to talk to you today about genome amplification
architecture. So about one in five cancers
amplify their oncogenes on extra chromosomal DNA or
ecDNA, as opposed to within chromosomal
regions called homogeneously staining regions or HSRs.
And these two genome architectures produce very
different patterns of copy number variation across cells in the
population. So if you look across a tumor or a cell
line, ecDNA-bearing cells show a broad, continuous
distribution of copies per cell. In contrast,
HSR-bearing cells produce this narrow, more uniform
peak.And this difference is largely
driven by how these elements are inherited.
Chromosomes are inherited equally into daughter cells, while ecDNAs are
unevenly segregated during cell division.
And this uneven segregation of ecDNA produces a lot of
diversity. So under drug pressure, this
diversity may enable adaptation through a bet hedging
strategy, where different cells with different levels of copies are
primed for different environments.
Another striking feature of ecDNA cancers are the structural
plasticities. So these elements can be eliminated under
drug pressure, and they can also reintegrate into chromosomes.
And so today I want to focus on this plasticity, and I want to talk
about where a gene is amplified or where it's located,
whether it's on ecDNA or HSRs, will have different functional
consequences at the gene, genome, and population level.
So studying ecDNA is surprisingly challenging.
In bulk whole-genome sequencing data, ecDNA is
essentially indistinguishable from HSRs.
So these two can have similar copy numbers, they can have
similar gene expression levels, and they often amplify the
same types of genes, which include oncogenes and regulatory
elements. And so the only method that really distinguishes
ecDNA and HSRs is
fluorescence in situ hybridization or FISH.
And in this approach, we use fluorescent probes that bind to specific
DNA loci, and if those loci are amplified on
ecDNA, you'll see these many dispersed
puncta or signals that are shown here in this metaphase cell,
where oncogenes like c-MYC, ERBB2, and CDC6 are all
amplified on ecDNA.
But the challenge with imaging is that it's low
and very time intensive. If we want to quantify the number of
ecDNA per cell or cell nuclei,
this often requires manual counting, which does not
scale. So to address this, my group has developed
several AI-based methods to automate the detection and quantification of
ecDNA from imaging data. We've also built
resources to map ecDNA and HSRs
across model systems. So for example,
CytoCellDB,
it's a resource that provides experimentally
validated annotations for over 500 DepMap cell
lines in order to help us better understand which systems harbor
ecDNA versus HSRs. So with these tools in
place,
we can now turn to functional studies of ecDNA.
And I want to start with one-- I want to introduce you to one model
system that is found in this island here with
high ERBB2 copy number variation and high ERBB2
expression. And so taking this model system, we
can better explore and understand the landscape of genes amplified on the
ecDNA. We can also, with long-read sequencing, we can know the
size of the ecDNA, which in this case is about three megabases.
Importantly, when we do metaphase FISH experiments
on this particular cell line, we can see that there's a broad
range of ecDNA copies per cell from roughly
100 to over 1,000. And this actually
translates to a substantial difference in DNA burden
with ecDNA comprising anywhere from about 4% in
these low cells to about 30% of the total
cellular DNA in these high cells. And what's interesting is
that when we look at this in other ecDNA model systems, there seems to
be a general phenomena here of this type of range.
So we're interested in characterizing the difference between these
extreme ends of this distribution.
And in order to do that, we developed an
approach to
sort live cells. For this particular model
system, we use an ecDNA proxy, which is HER2,
an antibody which has a fluorophore attached.
Because ERBB2 is amplified on ecDNA, HER2 is the
encoding protein. So we reasoned that
potentially high HER2 cells would have more ecDNA and low HER2
cells would have less ecDNA. And we confirmed this through several different
experiments. We performed FACS and collected these cells for
metaphase FISH and indeed showed that high
HER2 cells have much more ecDNA than low HER2
cells. And they also have this graded relationship between
HER2 intensity and ecDNA level. We also show that these
have differences in total DNA with immunofluorescence assays.
So this ability to isolate cells with these extreme ecDNA
levels now allows us to perform functional genomic
studies.
So we
collected Resolve-Om single-cell multi-omics data
across six different cell lines, including those with
ecDNA and HSRs. And this allows us to capture
the entire genome, so whole genome and transcriptome from the
same single cell. So we've produced this data on thousands of
cells across these cell lines. And importantly, our data
preserves this full distribution of ecDNA
dosage across the cells that we see in our imaging experiments.
We also see the
clear relationship between HER2 protein and ecDNA
dosage scaling.
And then we asked a simple question, does the gene expression
scale with ecDNA dosage, or do specific transcripts
scale?And to answer this, we order the
cells along this dosage trajectory by inferring ecDNA
levels in every single cell. And then we quantify
how different molecular layers, like DNA, RNA,
and protein, co-vary with that dosage.
So at the DNA level, you can see this very tight relationship
between genes that are co-amplified on the same ecDNA.
And this is to be expected. At the RNA level, we see more
variability, but we also observe this coordinated scaling
for both ecDNA amplified genes as well as some chromosomal
non-amplified genes that are important to growth and translation.
And at the protein level, HER2 abundance shows a very similar trend.
And what we did next was really important.
We wanted to compare these scaling relationships between ecDNA and
HSR systems. And when we quantify the number of
transcripts that significantly co-vary with dosage and
how tightly they co-vary, how tightly they follow this relationship,
we actually saw a very clear difference between ecDNA systems and
HSR systems. And this suggests to us that coordinated
gene expression scaling is an emergent
population property of ecDNA biology.
We then asked whether this architecture,
ecDNA versus HSR, also changes how individual genes
behave. So using the same data, we can look at
transcriptional yield, or does more gene dosage equal
more transcript? So we modeled transcriptional yield as a function of gene
dosage. And what we found is that these are all genes that are
amplified on the ecDNA, but they all have very different scaling behavior.
Some have more linear scaling, while others have nonlinear and saturating
dynamics. But what was really interesting to us
is looking at how the scaling relationships change when ecDNA is
reintegrated back into the chromosome.
So we have a quasi-isogenic model system in which the parental
line amplifies the same genes on
ecDNA as a descendant line that amplifies them on
HSRs. And when we compare the scaling relationships between
these two model systems, we noticed that certain
scaling relationships change very significantly, as shown by,
for example, PVT1.
So PVT1 is an oncogenic non-coding RNA.
And when looking at our model system, we
see the genes over in this area are the ones that scale the strongest with
ecDNA dosage. So PVT1 happens to be one of the ones that
scale the strongest. And what was very interesting
to us is that
the dominant isoform of PVT1, exon 1-2, shows
this clear co-variation with ecDNA dosage,
as well as with the Myc target gene expression program.
And this is true for two or more
ecDNA model systems that I'm showing here.
But when you have the HSR state, this collapses and this
coordination is lost. So this suggests that the genome
architecture in this case directly tunes regulation and
downstream transcriptional programming for Myc in this
case. We next asked whether
this heterogeneity is just a byproduct or
whether it's something that might be actively maintained by these populations.
And to test this, we sorted again our cells, our live cells, into high
and low populations and cultured them separately.
And then we tracked the number of ecDNAs per cell nucleus
longitudinally
over time. And what you can see here is a striking
result that within two to three generations,
both of these populations converge back to the original distribution.
And this is a rapid restoration that suggests that maybe this
heterogeneity is not just random, but actively regulated.
And for this to happen, we think two things must be true.
First, the inheritance, as shown by this model, has to be
biased, with ecDNA unevenly distributing more
often than not or more often than expected by chance.
And then the cells with higher levels of ecDNA may have a growth
advantage, so they proceed through the cell cycle faster.
We confirmed both of these experimentally with live cell imaging
with our ecDNA cell line and our control system,
which shows about a 10% difference on
average in difference of ecDNA or DNA
between daughter cells. And then our growth assays showed
division advantages for the high cells shown more in red
here.
We also built stochastic AI models that incorporated these
parameters, and we were able to recapitulate this observed
redistribution dynamic.
So in summary, ecDNA provides cancer cells with
distinct evolutionary strategies.
Rather than maybe by discrete clonal states,
the ecDNA creates this continuous spectrum of gene dosage
across cells that's maintained and enables the population level
diversity that we see. We know that non-Mendelian inheritance
is present and may be combined with biased inheritance and
division.
This maintains and restores this level of diversity.
And at the molecular level, ecDNA alters transcriptional
scaling, and this actually translates dosage
variation into the wide range of phenotypic outcomes that may be
important for selection. And so looking forward with
advances in AI and single-cell multi-omics,
we are increasingly able to integrate these data across biological
layers and understand how these systems function as a whole.
And ultimately, we are doing this work to better
understand how ecDNA-driven cancers adapt and how we can
more effectively target them.
And with that, I'd like to thankMy lab and my collaborators
and my funders, in particular pointing out
Jingting Chen, Yue Wang, and Oliver Cope, who are the lead authors on
the paper that I presented. I also want to mention Kriti Shukla, who's a
student that's here. If you're interested, you can check out her poster tomorrow.
And thank you for your attention. Happy to take questions.
Fantastic. Wonderful talk, Elizabeth.
Probably have time for one question if someone wants to come up, but I can start
with one.
I'm interested, you show that the total DNA abundance seems to correlate with the
HER2 levels, and I'm curious if the percentage of
ecDNA is consistent across HER2 levels or if most of that can
be accounted for by total ecDNA mass.
Yes. So within a single cell, there's a large amount of
diversity in terms of what genes are amplified on which
ecDNA. In this particular model system, it's more homogeneous and
ERBB2 is amplified across. Yeah.
Hi.
Hi. Very interesting. So one quick question.
When during cancer evolution does circular
DNA arise? Is it early or later?
Oh, so that's a good question. There's a couple of papers that have come out
recently that have shown that it does arise early.
So I think this is still ongoing and active research, but yeah.
Okay. So might be an early driver, right?
Yeah, potentially.
And what is limiting the amplification?
Is it the oncogene itself or is it also other genes?
Yeah, that's a terrific question. We're interested in that as well.
So I think the theories out there that I have seen is
resource burden and burden of having that
many copies, right? Like can you imagine 1,000?
But it's really interesting that they are maintained.
Up to that level, even 1,000 copies of ERBB2, there's a
reason why they're being maintained, and we are hoping to figure that out. Yeah.
Thank you.
Our
next speaker is Dr. Joseph Chen from MSKCC.
All right. Thanks so much for the introduction.
So today I'll be sharing our unpublished work on histological
transformation, which is one of the more extreme forms of
lineage plasticity where tumor cells can change their histological
identity under pressure. And this can take place in lung
cancer as an escape from targeted therapies like EGFR,
through the switch from adenocarcinoma to small cell lung cancer.
And it's thought that the transformed small cell adopts a phenotype
that's independent of the originally targeted gene program, even
though it retains the same driver mutation.
And oftentimes, the ADNO persists
alongside the transformed small cell, requiring treatment of
both cancer types at once and complicating, compounding
the risk of
toxicity and relapse. And multiple sequencing
studies have implicated p53 and RB1 loss
as a key but insufficient step towards
transformation with other signaling changes thought to
consolidate this process, including MYC,
AKT, JAK/STAT, and loss of Notch
signaling. However,
most of these studies have relied on bulk sequencing, mouse
models, and small patient cohorts that are unable to capture the full scope
of tumor diversity, both within and across patient tumors.
And a lot of these studies also focus on
EGFR mutant transformation when EGFR wild-type
transformation can take place as well in the absence of any treatment
pressure.
And at MSK, we found that EGFR wild-type transformation
has poor survival approaching that of de novo small cell.
So all of this raises the questions: What tumor intrinsic
reprogramming drives tumor trajectories in the larger patient
population? To what extent does genotype
define the permissible state space?
And what tumor extrinsic factors from therapy and microenvironment
shape this process altogether?
Now, it's also important to recognize that small cell displays a lot of
plasticity at baseline, where you can get a switch from the
classical neuroendocrine ASCL1 high state to a
more pro-metastatic immune cold Neurona1 variant,
and further to these inflamed and non-neuroendocrine subtypes as well,
with mouse studies implicating MYC, MAPK, and Notch
signaling.
But it's unclear how prevalent these mechanisms are in
patients and how plasticity within small cell relates to
small cell transformation itself.
And so to explore this, we teamed up with the Runan lab to perform
single-cell sequencing in 47 tumors from 24
patients with transformed and combined neuroendocrine histology
across both EGFR mutant and wild-type contexts, along with
appropriate controls. And by comparing the pre versus
never transformed ADNO and the transformed versus de novo small
cell, we sought to capture the early and late features of
plasticity that could explain the foreshortened survival
that we see in transformed patients.
To contextualize our cohort, Swanand, a medical
resident in the lab,
examined the underlying mutational landscape of this disease
using mashed MSK-impact data and found
substantial chromatin instability, whole genome
doubling, and high TMB
across transformed tumors that were associated with
APOBEC hypermutation and defective mismatch repair across both
groups. With EGFR wild type also having additional
smoking-related signature and homologous repair deficiency
consistent with chromatin
instability.Across both
groups had distinct mutational profiles, but
converged on activating mutations in
PI3K/AKT pathway, suggesting a shared
route to
plasticity.
Turning to our single-cell data, we found a substantial tumor
state diversity across ano, squamous, small cell
subtypes, and an interesting YAP1 high
non-neuroendocrine reversion following small cell
transformation.
We also found that in B, the transformed tumors occupy a much
wider spread across the UMAP plot compared to control,
consistent with increased
phenotypic diversity.
And at the individual patient level, we also saw high small cell
subtype diversity compared to de novo small cell that tends
to be more subtype pure.
We wanted to model the transitions between these tumor states,
and we did this using pseudotime, which is a popular
single-cell method that estimates the evolutionary ordering of cells
across continuous cell state changes.
We could then calculate the probability of each lineage per cell
and associated gene markers. However, comparing
multiple pseudotimes across patients at once is
challenging because of the unbalanced representation of cell
states across patients. And so Mamie, a
computational biologist in the lab, developed a method called
SCWC, which uses dynamic time
warping and an expectation maximization
framework to identify an optimal pseudotime
alignment across the entire cohort.
This outperforms other methods that are focused more on
pairwise alignment and gives us a single unified
representation of tumor evolution, where we can see that
ano typically transforms to subtype A and then
N across patients. We can then identify genes
turning on and off along the early, middle, and late stages of
this process, including ASCL1 rising
first before IRD1, and interesting drug targets like TROP2,
EZH2, and DLL3.
We can also focus on the transition window between ano and
small cell and assess for recurrent gene programs,
which identified a basal intermediate state that
arises from early differentiated
secretory and suprabasal phenotypes before ultimately
transitioning to small cell,
thus suggesting that a reversal of the normal airway
development might be facilitating the final transformation to
neuroendocrine state.
This was associated with early inflammatory NF-kappa B and
JAK STAT pathways and intermediate stress pathways in a reactive
oxygen species, AKT, mTOR, and
hypoxia, suggesting both tumor intrinsic and extrinsic
features of the basal state.
As an orthogonal approach, Manny, a grad student in the lab,
used Hotspot to identify gene modules within the single-cell data.
He found module four, which closely resembled the
hypoxic basal state of
our SCWC analysis,
and interestingly, found that this module was enriched,
particularly in the transformed setting, both in ano and
across small cell subtypes.
He also found other modules that correspond to histologies beyond
neuroendocrine, including mesenchymal, squamous, and the
non-neuroendocrine state.
We wondered how the basal state relates to these other
histologies and considered several examples of
ano bifurcating into squamous and small cell
lineages,
as well as one case where the small cell
excuse me,
differentiates further to the non-neuroendocrine
state. We found that the basal state
increases within the ano prior to
transformation,
but persists along the squamous trajectory, consistent
with the possibility that there may
exist a multipotent basal precursor to transformation.
And if these basal tumor cells can't overcome the bottleneck
to transform to small cell, then they may be diverted to an
alternative squamous fate instead.
So we next turn to our matched Xenium spatial imaging to
examine the intermediate and terminal states in situ,
with analysis led by Manny.
Excuse me.
And found a recurring spatial motif where the immune
cold subtype N
and an interesting NOTCH1 high subtype A in purple, sit at the
tumor immune interface, effectively sequestering the red
subtype A from the surrounding immune microenvironment,
thus suggesting that these tumor states may be spatially
organizing with respect to immune
pressure. However, when we focus on the tumor
subtypes alone, we see that the ano
co-localizes most with the tumor core more than
any other tumor subtype.
And we wondered whether this had implications on the temporal ordering of tumor
subtypes. And so performed this trajectory analysis that
found that indeed ano sits closest to the tumor core
before it subdivides into NOTCH1 high and IRD1 high
states that correspond respectively to
low versus high neuroendocrine marker expression.We
also found that the tumor core was associated with hypoxic
markers HIF1A and SLC2A1,
suggesting that hypoxic stress may be associated with these plastic
intermediate states. We looked at differential expression and
compared between tumor subtypes and found one interesting
gene, FOX2B, that was upregulated early on in the tumor
core and even more in the neuroendocrine high subtype N.
This was interesting to us because FOX2B was one of the most differentially
expressed between transformed tumors versus de novo, and is a
known driver of neuronal development and plasticity
within a related neuroendocrine cancer called neuroblastoma.
This gene was associated with pathways in neuroendocrine and neuronal
differentiation, as well as EGFR TKI resistance.
And to test this, Amin, a grad student in the Rudin Lab,
obtained EGFR mutant lung adeno cell lines and subjected them to
p53 and Rb1 loss with and without FOX2B
overexpression. And even though FOX2B did not induce
full morphological small cell transformation, it did
robustly increase neuroendocrine markers synaptophysin,
chromogranin, and ASCL1, and suppressed EGFR and
phospho-EGFR,
which was all further enhanced by inhibition of the Notch effector Rest.
We also found one interesting case where the
FOX2B-positive transformed small cell had
a subpopulation that acquired an endogenous deletion of
chromosome 4p that encompasses the FOX2B gene,
and results in depletion of the FOX2B expression and the
emergence of a non-neuroendocrine state, reinforcing the idea that
this FOX2B may be licensing this
neuroendocrine identity.
So in the remaining time I have, I just want to mention one
new direction that we're following that builds upon the observation
that SDK11 and KEAP1 mutations are enriched in
EGFR wild-type transformation. Now, these mutations are
associated with the worst prognosis in lung adeno, are largely
mutually exclusive to Rb1 loss, and have
been implicated in metabolic rewiring and
plasticity in the form of squamous transformation.
However, their role in neuroendocrine histology is poorly
defined. And even though these mutations are rare in small
cell, they're actually more common in a high-grade neuroendocrine
cancer called large cell, at a rate that exceeds even lung
adeno.
Now, large cell neuroendocrine cancer is an aggressive disease with median
survival of less than one year following metastasis, and no proven
targeted or immunotherapies, partly because it acts as a
molecular mimic of both lung adeno and small cell at once,
with adeno-like mutations like SDK11 and
KEAP1 coinciding with transcriptional subtypes
similar to small cell.
But large cell also displays a unique
gastrointestinal-like subtype H that's enriched for
HNF4A and chemoresistance.
And so we hypothesized that SDK11 and
KEAP1 loss may drive downstream epigenetic rewiring to
create a unique spectrum of neuroendocrine to GI plasticity that may
facilitate metabolic rewiring and chemoresistance.
And so to explore, we again teamed up with the Rudin Lab to perform
single-nuc RNA and RNA Atac-seq of large cell
patient tumors, with analysis led by Ahmed, Mamie,
and Manny.
We
further hypothesized that there may exist a master transcription
factor that controls the switch between these neuroendocrine and
GI subtypes. And so we constructed a gene
regulatory network using the CENIC framework to
identify subtype-specific regulons, and then performed in
silico ablation of
these TF nodes to predict maximal disruption of
regulatory flow between
subtype-specific regulons. This nominated a number of
interesting candidates that are predicted to control the
switch between subtypes, which we're continuing to explore.
And I think I'm running out of time, so I'll just quickly summarize that
we find that adeno to small cell transformation is much more
complicated than a binary switch, and leads to a
multiverse of different states, small cell subtypes,
alternative histologies, that all stem from
hypoxic intermediate states, including a basal
precursor state that's associated with inflammatory and stress
signaling. We find that the tumor states spatially organize with respect to
hypoxic and immune pressures, and that FOX2B may be
a driver of the neuroendocrine state
with EGFR suppression. And finally, we're exploring
SDK11 and KEAP1 loss in large cell as an alternative
regulatory axis of neuroendocrine to GI plasticity.
And so I just want to say that this work would not be possible
without the amazing people in my lab,
and my brilliant collaborators and mentors,
and with the main drivers of this work highlighted in
bold. Thank you so much for your attention.
Fantastic. We can take one question from the audience.
Awesome work, Joe. Quick question about
thisOverexpression of Fox2B
in an in vitro, we were able to gain those neuroendocrine marker, which is amazing.
Can you comment on the integrin signaling in this process,
which we
listened on Sunday, where the integrin signaling is preventing the
neuroendocrine transformation in prostate cancer?
Yeah, that's a great question. I don't think that was specifically
tested in the western blots. We have single-cell data,
actually, for those cell lines.
And I don't recall seeing the integrin
pathways,
the hits specifically, but I think that's something that we need to look more
deeply anyways.
Awesome. Thank you.
Thank you.
Great. Thank you, Joe.
Next, we have Nick Godzik from the Broad Institute, who's going to talk
to us about his work on image-based screening to
study pancreatic cancer plasticity.
All right. Hello, everyone.
My name's Nick Godzik, and I'm an MIT student.
I'm a graduate student at MIT in Paul Pulcini's lab, and I also work at the Broad
Institute.
And I'm excited to talk to you guys today about our work identifying
regulators of
cancer plasticity using optical pooled screens.
So,
just a little bit of framing.
Pancreatic cancers like PDAC,
or in PDAC,
basal or mesenchymal-like programs are often associated with more aggressive
disease and poorer therapeutic responses, whereas
epithelial or more classical-like programs are often
more treatment permissive. And as you may have heard from other
presenters at this conference, there's this idea of therapeutically targeting
specific cell states.
And our team is also interested in this.
But in order to do that well,
we need to not just understand which states exist, but what
actually controls the movement between these states,
by moving beyond traditional retrospective analyses.
So, in order to understand these regulators,
we want to perform a causal genetic screen, to identify
them, with the interest of potentially
biasing tumors towards more treatment-sensitive states.
And in particular, we're interested in both genetic and epigenetic regulators
of this plasticity. So, before getting into
the screen itself, I want to
define a few terms explicitly. So when we talk about lineages or clones,
it's basically just a family of cells that descend from one
starting clone, or one starting cell, excuse me.
And plasticity
is where there is one parental cell,
which is able to give progeny in multiple cell states.
And using this explicit definition,
plasticity becomes a lineage-resolved property.
So it requires us to know both the
state of the cells at the end of the assay, as well as the
initial state information
of that clone.
With that in mind, if we want to turn this into
a lineage-resolved
causal genetic screen, there's a few pieces of information that we need to
encode into the assay. That being the perturbational
identity of what that cell received, the initial state information, so in our
case, is it epithelial or mesenchymal?
And we need to encode a static lineage barcode, which can help us decode that
clonal structure. And then additionally, we need some kind of end-state phenotype,
which we can use to encode or inform
the end state
of that cell.
So the way that we did this is we designed a dual guide
RNA vector system, which encodes all three pieces of information, the
perturbational identity, the initial state, and the lineage barcode.
And we introduced that into an inducible CRISPRi
PDAC cell line, which was derived from patients.
And what we did is we transduced this
perturbation library into the cells,
both into a population that was initially epithelial and
mesenchymal, which we separated using a cell sorter
immunofluorescence marker. Then we bottlenecked those cells, and then
we basically clonally expanded them for 14 days under
perturbation.
And once we did that, after 14 days, we did an endpoint assay where we
did optical pooled screening, where basically we do
fixed immunofluorescence
imaging of cells, in addition to in situ sequencing, which can decode a
barcode,
which encodes the perturbation identity, the initial state, and the lineage.
Okay.
And importantly, one advantage
of using an optical pooled screen is that we're able to scale the number of cells
up dramatically, which allows us to
be able to do a lineage-resolved
screen.
Just a little bit more detail about how optical pooled screens work.
Basically, we introduced a pooled genetic library into cells.
Then we do some kind of experimental assay, and then we do image phenotyping, which
can be a variety of different things.
But
in our experiment, it was these
morphology-associated immunofluorescence stains, as
well as PDAC-specific stains, which was able to help us decode the
the
final state of all the cells in our assay.
And what we do from here is we basically perform cell segmentation,
and then we have a library of predefined mathematical functions
that we use to derive image-based features.
And then we have this-Data structure, which is all our image-based features,
as well as our decoded information here.
We get that information from doing the in situ sequencing, which is basically
iterative rounds of reading bases over multiple rounds, which helps us
reconstruct those barcodes, and finally, to decode the perturbation, initial
state, and clonal identity of those cells.
So
what we do next
is take that
data matrix and do dimensionality reduction.
And you can see in this phenotypic state space that the epithelial-mesenchymal
axis is really well represented. And we can use this to basically
perform a binary classification of the final state into either E or M.
And what we do from here is really important.
So we take all these individual single cells that you see here in the state space,
and we aggregate them into their clonal and initial
state bins,
and then derive a single clonal
metric, which is just the proportion of
cells in the final state.
And the way that that looks here is you can see this figure of a control
perturbation. So you can see here on the x-axis, these are all the clones
that initially started E for this control perturbation.
And you can see that a majority of them remained in the epithelial state
at the end of the assay. But there are a few that transitioned.
So you can interpret this as there is a little bit of intrinsic E to M plasticity
in our model.
So once you introduce a perturbation, the
question changes and is, does this perturbation shift the final
clone-level state distributions relative to that control?
And another way that might be a little more visually appealing to interpret this in
one plot is these cumulative plots, where now we're looking at, this
is showing the trace of the control here for initial
state. And you can see that overall, this validated
perturbation shifts the state distributions
relative to that control, towards the
M state.
Okay.
So, that was just an example of a single perturbation.
Obviously, we're able to scale this up to many perturbations.
So in our experiment, we were able to profile nearly 900
perturbations across 20 million cells and
150,000 lineages, with an average of around 75 clones
per perturbation and initial state bin.
Again, the next thing, or I guess the next thing that we want to do is we want to
categorize all those perturbations into distinct
behaviors.
And the way that we do that is, again, using the effect sizes of these
cumulative plots. And I'm going to describe this using
two well-validated positive controls from our
assay. Another way you can visualize this is using this
transition rate diagram. So the first one I'm going to
talk about here is ZEB1. You guys are probably familiar with ZEB1.
It's a canonical EMT marker. So when we knock it down, in our case
or in our model system, what we see is, regardless of the initial
state, we see an E biasing behavior, where if the cell
started in the M state initially, those clones are more likely to
transition to the E state, and the same is true if they started in the E state.
And we can plot that by basically plotting the effect size on this 2D scatter
plot. And those kind of perturbations that are E biasing will exist in this
top left quadrant.
GRL2 is an EMT suppressor, so when we knock it out in our model system,
what we see is a strong M biasing behavior.
So if the clone started initially in the E state,
it's more likely to transition to the M state, and if the clone started in the M
state, it's more likely to remain in the M state.
This is all relative to controls
or non-targeting perturbations. Okay.
And then the final category that we're very interested
in are these things that we're calling plasticity regulators,
which are very interesting because regardless of the initial state or agnostic of
the initial state, they're going to exhibit more plasticity.
So they're more likely to transition to the other state.
So if it's E, it'll transition to M, and vice versa.
We think these are particularly interesting because, to our knowledge, people
haven't really investigated these.
And part of our effort is to identify whether these factors actually exist.
And also, there could be some stabilizing factors which we'll call maintenance
factors, which can also be interesting.
And both these two final categories could be therapeutically
interesting because they're kind of distinct to what people traditionally think
about in this space.
So
now we're
at a point where we're talking about the actual screening results.
So
I can describe, you can see here in the diagram again, in the scatter plot, you
would expect that the ZEB1 associated
factors are going to be up here, and the EMT
related factors are going to be down here.
And then the most interesting ones we call the putative plasticity regulators
are going to exist in this region of the plot.
So,
show those. So,
you can see here these are all the factors that we've identified.
The ones that we find to be most interesting are these
H3K9 methylation related factors, including
SUV39H1 and H2, as well as other factors in that
category.
And is there anything else I want to say here? Yeah.
Oh, one more thing I wanted to point out.
Because we are doing a dual guide system, we're able to
do... multiple, two different perturbations per
cell. And we also did one which is quite interesting.
We did a ZEB1 knockdown with GRL2, which we find interesting
because it means that a ZEB1 knockout is dominant to a GRL2 knockout.
So then just expanding a little bit on the SUV39H1 and H2 factors.
They're H3K9 trimethylation
regulators, and they
support heterochromatin. So knocking them out will
reduce heterochromatin, and this lays
us to the hypothesis that there's some kind of chromatin-mediating plasticity
occurring in our model system.
Also, there's some support from our collaborators who have also identified this in
another screen, where they're looking at MET-related factors.
And
with that, obviously some of this work is relatively preliminary.
So what we plan to do next is validate most of the hits that we've identified using
a follow-up screen, which is higher power and also is paralog-aware, so we're going
to look at
multiple things per pathway and basically try to identify and be confident
that
the biology that we're seeing is real.
We also want to generalize this to other cell line models or other model
systems in general. Potentially want to do some mechanistic follow-up using
epigenetic sequencing or RNA seq.
And also we're interested in the drug ability of this chromatin
axis in our model system, so using
SUV39 drugs or some kind of KRAS drugs to see
if there can be a combinatorial effect
that could be useful here.
All right.
So in summary, I guess what we were trying to show here is that
plasticity can be screened as a lineage resolve phenotype, and it can reveal new
biology which is invisible to other conventional
endpoint assays.
And with that,
I just want to thank everyone for listening, and I want to give a big
thanks to my collaborators and funding sources and in particular, my research team,
Mike, Arnav, Russell, and Julian, which were incredible team
to work with, and I wouldn't be here without them. So thank you.
Yeah. Fantastic presentation. I actually have
quite a bit of a few questions, but I'll start with one.
Okay.
So I find these plasticities regulators really fascinating.
Mm-hmm.
And how does it tie to the cell cycle?
Proliferation.
Yeah.
How much does the proliferation plays into it?
Does any factors actually affect the-
Yeah
... proliferation as well?
That's a great question. So because we were culturing these for... I can't go back.
Okay. Well, because we were culturing this for 14 days, we actually had to
specifically decrease the perturbations that we were
investigating to just look at things that didn't have a growth advantage or
disadvantage, because over 14 days, they would basically drop out of the screen,
and we wouldn't be able to detect them.
But that is a really interesting question, and we do see a very big growth
difference between the two states, and that's a confounding variable in our screen.
I was wondering whether you can use some dyes that trace the cell division.
Oh, I see.
Yeah.
Sure.
But
yeah.
Very interesting in terms of
histone 3K9 trimethylation. I was wondering, do you
see histone K9 demethylase
enriching your maintenance or the stabilizer
categories?
Yeah, that's a great question. So we were
less powered to identify things in that category, just the way that the
distributions were shaped.
But in the follow-up screen, we're going to include more of those demethylases and
other
chromatin factors. So we're hoping to look at that a little
bit more in detail. But at the moment, we don't have too much data on that.
I see. Thank you.
Mm-hmm.
Very cool talk. So SUV39H1
is sex-linked, SUV39H2 isn't.
Mm-hmm.
And sex chromosome loss is pervasive
across tumors. Do you see any difference in
terms of sex effect and/or
loss, gain, presence of XP
among the
tumor clones and/or cell lines that you're using for this?
That's a good question. So, I wasn't aware of that.
But,
we're only using a single cell line to do this experiment, so all
the clones are actually derived from one original cell line.
So we haven't really looked at that information, but it could be interesting to
look at that potentially in
that map data or something like that to look at that further. Yeah.
Good talk.
Thank you.
All right. So
All right. Thank-
Thank you so much.
Yeah.
Thank you.
So our last speaker today is
Yue Wu from UCSD.
Good afternoon, everyone. Thank you for having me here.
I'm really happy to come here and share what we're
doing recently. So I am Yue Wu from the
Acker Lab of the Salk Institute of Biological Studies,
and I have no financial disclosure to make.
So, I would like to share how we use joint
profiling of methylation and the 3D genome structures to
study glioma heterogeneity. Oops.
So the adult type diffuse glioma can be separated into two
worlds based on the IDH mutation status.
The IDH mutant glioma are low-grade, slow growing, with
median survival greater than 15 years.
And the mutant IDH would inhibit the TEAD enzyme and
creating a genome-wide gain of DNA
methylationIDH wild-type glioblastoma, on the other
hand, are high grade and aggressive, with median survival less
than 15 months.
The genome is profoundly restructured, frequently harbors
EGFR amplification, PTEN loss, chromosome 7 gain, or
10 losses. The genome displays loss of methylation phenotype and
extreme chromosome instability.
So our lab is interested in how DNA methylation and the 3D genome
structure together regulate glioma progression.
Therefore, we jointly profiled the two modalities on
each single cell from 43 primary glioma
tumors.
Among those samples, 25 of them are IDH wild-type GBM,
and 18 are IDH mutant gliomas.
We ended up getting 72,000
nuclei passing QC.
We annotate the cell type based on a reference human body cell
type atlas.
And here, these 3tSNE embedding shows how tumor cells
cluster with each other by DNA methylation on the left, chromatin
contact in the middle, and read coverage similar to copy
number on the right.
With orange being cancer cells, if you compare the methylation
embedding on the top row and the donor
coloring on methylation embedding on the bottom row, we found that
normal cells cluster by cell type and the
cancer cells cluster by donor, suggesting that the cancer
methylome is profoundly reshaped in a patient-specific way.
And then if we color the IDH mutation status on the bottom,
we found that the IDH mutant tumor cells and the wild-type
tumor cells harbor almost non-overlapping regions in
the embeddings, suggesting that IDH mutation being
the main driver of cross-patient methylation
diversity.
Today, I want to share three key results from our study
related with IDH mutant glioma, wild-type GBM, and for both.
So to start with, in the IDH mutant glioma, we found shared
clonal region of cancer cells and the methylation-defined
astrocytes.
So the IDH mutant cancers are thought to originate from
OPCs and glial progenitors. And here in this patient,
we found a similar connection between cancer cells and the
methylation-defined astrocytes, where they both contain the
1p19q codeletion
here, and the cancer cells further contain the chromosome 17 loss.
This suggests shared clonal origin between the cell types.
And if we look at the methylation embedding, these CMV-containing
astrocytes cluster separately from the cancer cells.
If we look at the methylation, those tumor astrocytes,
the methylation pattern is more similar to a healthy astrocyte than the
cancer cells at the GFAP locus, which is the marker gene
for astrocytes.
And then we ask where are the methylation changes happening?
We compare the methylation between cancer cells, tumor astrocytes,
and healthy astrocytes, and we found that these tumor astrocytes occupy an
intermediate methylation profile.
And
most of the differentially methylated regions, or DMRs,
gain the methylation in cancers compared to the
other cell types.
And these DMRs are enriched of lineage-related
TF motifs such as DLX1 and
TCF3.
Fewer sites lost methylation in cancers, and they are enriched
of
stem cell-related TF motifs such as OLIG2 and
ASCL1.
Gene ontology analysis tells us that cancer cells
silence negative regulation
of growth-related signaling pathways by DNA methylation
and activate
astrocyte fate commitment and mesenchymal transitions
programs by demethylation.
Now let's take a closer look at the cancer cells.
The cancer cells are not a homogenous population.
Rather, they polarize in two different cell states.
So the transcriptome study reveals that glioblastoma
recapitulate normal brain development, and they can be split
into different cell states, such as OPC-like,
NPC-like, astrocyte-like, and mesenchymal-like.
Notice that a lot of
cells show the transition cell states and they fall on the
intermediate space. We think the epigenetic
can explain why we see such transition cell states by transcriptome.
Therefore, we use the top
1,000 differentially methylated regions or chromatin loops
that best separate cell types during human brain development
and use these markers to evaluate what normal cell
type the cancer cells are most similar to.
Therefore, we can get
cell state annotation separately by methylation
and
3D genome structure.
In this way, we are able to study how DNA methylation and
3D genome structure together regulate cell state
dynamics.
We found repeatedly across patients that certain
tumor cells
have mismatched DNA methylation and chromatin contact
statesFor example, the same cancer
cells from the patient are clustered by 3D
genome structure on the left and methylation on the right.
The orange cells suggest that
these cells are OPC-like
by DNA methylation and AC-like by
3D genome structure.
We think they may represent an intermediate state when OPC-like
cells transition towards AC-like cells,
where the
DNA structure change happens earlier than methylation.
Take the SOX9 locus as an example.
The middle
plot shows the intermediate state, and you may find a
clear domain boundary that is similar to AC-like
cell states. However, their methylation profile is more
similar to the OPC-like state than the AC-like state.
I think this mechanism underlies why we see
a continuum of transcriptome state in the previous
plot.
So intra-tumor heterogeneity involves more than just
epigenetic state transitions. Also, there are
genome rearrangements, such as ecDNAs.
EcDNAs are circular, acentric DNA fragments
outside of normal chromosomes. They lack centromere and
therefore segregate unequally during division, generating copy
number heterogeneity. We are able to detect ecDNAs
using enrichment of transchromosome contacts at single cell
level.
So in our cohort, ecDNAs are
exclusively detected among wild-type GBMs,
where more than half of the patients contain some
sort of ecDNA. And the most frequently affected
oncogenes found on ecDNA are EGFR from chromosome
7 and CDK4 from chromosome 12.
We found that a certain form of ecDNA structure may associate with
unique methylation identity.
Take this wild-type GBM patient as an
example. The same cancer cells are
clustered by methylation on the top row and the ecDNA
structure on the bottom row. We found that
both modalities separate the cancer cells into two clusters, and
one
ecDNA cluster
maps directly onto a methylation cluster, MC2.
If we merge the DNA contact from the two ecDNA clusters,
we found that they differ in amplicon architectures.
So there is a unique deletion that occurs at the
EGFR locus, deleting the exon 2
to 7, creating a constitutively active receptor
called EGFRvIII, and it's associated with worse
prognosis.
The coverage
track on the left supports the presence of the very
different deletion that happens at EGFR, and we
observed that such deletion can be already observed from the normal
cells and is likely evolved later into
two separate cancer clones.
Bulk RNA-seq analysis supports the presence of
the two splicing variants of EGFR.
And then we ask,
what are the
methylation differences between the different ecDNA structures
across the donors? Where are they?
And we found that most of them actually occur genome-wide
and fewer on the ecDNA itself, suggesting the
epigenetic consequence happening both in cis and in trans.
And
we wonder, what are the TF motifs enriched at these DMRs?
The dot plot on the right suggests that it is actually
oncogene specific. Patients with EGFR
ecDNAs tend to be enriched with MAPK downstream
targets.
And a patient with, for example, GLI1 on the
ecDNA are enriched with Hedgehog signaling pathway targets and
these GLI1,
GLI2, and GLI3 motifs.
So essentially, we think
ecDNA is acting as a structural amplifier that rewires the cell's
methylation landscape to serve its own signaling process.
In summary, we studied in
IDH-mutant glioma, there are shared clonal region of cancer
cells and astrocytes. For both cancer types, there is
asynchronous regulation of chromatin architecture states
and the DNA methylation state, and that may explain why we see the
transcriptomes fall onto a continuum.
And for the wild-type glioblastoma, we show that within-patient
ecDNA heterogeneity shapes methylation sub clones.
Lastly, I will thank my advisor, Dr.
Joseph Acker, and my collaborators, Dr. Jesse Dixon and Dr.
Thomas Beaumont, who dissected the tumors from the patient.
And I would like to thank all the patients and their families.
I'm happy to take any questions. Thank you.
Thank you so much, Yue, for a great talk.
I think we have a question from the audience.
That is a tremendous amount of data from a large number of patients.
Congratulations on making some sense out of it.
I was curious, you mentioned that codeletion 1q 19q is
one of the common
co-occurringlesions with IDH
mutations. The other is P53
mutation or deletion. Did you have any P53 mutant clones
or patients among the oligodendrogliomas or
Grade 3 astrocytomas?
Yeah, for sure.
I think we have an onco print, but it's not on the presentation.
But we have a significant amount of patients having
P53 mutation, and I think we have eight
oligodendroglioma patients. But I couldn't remember
off of the
top of my head whether that particular patient has the P53 or not.
Yeah. So the reason I ask is that you tend to see more subclonal
heterogeneity in
P53 mutant patients. And I was wondering whether
you're able to pick out more
subclonal co-dominant clones and whether you see a different
pattern of evolution or bifurcation among the P53
mutants versus the 1q and 19q
co-deletions versus the EGFR-driven cases.
That's a good question. I never thought about associating with specific mutation
with the epigenetic of phenotypes we saw.
I will definitely look into that. Thank you for-
Look forward to it. Thanks.
Mm-hmm.
Thank you.
Any more questions from the audience?
If not, I have one more, and then I'll hand it over to Arnav.
So
the asynchrony between the 3D
chromatin confirmation changes and the DNA methylation changes
is quite fascinating. What's your thought with regard to the
mechanism of why the 3D
conformation change happened earlier, and what could be the
upstream factor that mediates that?
Yeah, great question. Actually, this is
something also observed in the normal tissues.
We have a previous publication on skeletal
muscles where the different types of fast and slow-twitching fibers
may switch
between each other by
regulation of the 3D genome, and that usually happens earlier
than methylation. I think why it's
acting like that because the 3D genome change is
easier than methylation.
So it's more flexible in defining cell types and adapt to
the environment.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Fantastic.
Just want to thank all the speakers for a fantastic set of talks.
And as all of you saw, we covered a number of disparate
diseases, methods, and
interesting biology throughout.
I tried my best to summarize some of the themes here,
and I'll just keep this high level and short.
So I think what we saw today is that we have an ever-expanding
genomic and functional genomics toolkit, and that includes both
DNA sequencing, single-cell methods, gene expression,
and amongst many other things.
There's a clear convergence in this day and age of clinical genomics, functional
genomics, and experimental design that enable our understanding of
causal relationships, and that's one thing
I think is worth emphasizing. We're sort of beyond the era of
characterizing genomic features of tumors and sort of in
the era of understanding what are the causal genes in various
contexts. And today we saw that can come from human studies, the studies
of exposures and how they affect genetic relationships,
treatments, and time series,
as well as model systems across mouse cell lines, ways in
which we profile. We can do functional genomics experiments and study
perturbations.
Importantly, the other thing we saw, which is
paramount to our current time, is the scale at which we can study
mouse and human tumors is unprecedented.
From the order of hundreds of thousands of patients to millions of cells.
And I think we're in an exciting time where we're learning really interesting
things about the genetics of tumors.
We'll stop there and
if there are any further questions, feel free to find some of the speakers here as
well who are at the front.
Thank you.
Thank you everyone for coming to this